so how you doing I'm doing great you
know just um she's doing what needs to
be done what does that mean I'm sorry
dad um why don't we just have lunch and
talk we can do that right please you
think that you have this under control
I understand why I do things it doesn't
make me any different you're just
embarrassed because I was like you know
I was like this amazing thing like your
special creation or something and you
know like Who I am now it was so
realistic I was trying to think in my
head if there was a movie that you could
share with people that they could watch
kind of an anticipation of seeing this
movie on its release I don't know if
there is one because I don't know that
I've ever seen addiction portrayed like
this was that an impression that you got
when you're first familiar with the
project that's I think that's why we
were both attracted to it in the first
place that it it it felt like and then
the memoirs felt this way as well very
honest and and unflinching and and
self-aware I think I think you know in
reading beautiful boy specifically I got
the sense that he was really burying his
soul and allowing I ultimately saw it is
a real generosity because he's sharing
this story for the benefit of anyone
else who has been involved with this
world and and and had to deal with these
things so I felt it was it was very raw
and very honest and uncomplicated
doesn't fall into the cliches that I
think you could easily fall into and
that's that's why I was drawn to it was
there something from the rehearsal
process
that kind of changed over time as you
guys started filming that was based more
on the emotions coming out of your work
together I think that was the the the
impression from the get-go and this
isn't a biopic and certainly like Nick
and
and Steve has told me David as well like
they were incredibly Jenna you know
generous and they're they're generous in
spirit and and and and licensed for us
to be able to primarily get what a
father and sons relationship would look
like when I tried I felt bad so I just
kept doing it
I thought with this movie more than a
lot of others that I've seen I just felt
that it was so realistic that I was
watching real life unfold on screen and
because most of your scenes are kind of
isolated from everyone else was there
something in particular that really
surprised you about the final product of
the movie well I love the way Felix
plays with time and therefore memory and
so how scenes intercut or images of of
them as a young boy and then you know
there he is off to college because that
being a parent that's the one thing you
you say all the time I just go so fast
it goes so fast how they get so big and
then seeing that unfold in the two hours
of this film and you you can't hold on
to life as a man in these moments as
much as you really dearly want to so I
thought that works so beautifully in in
the film can you talk about working with
the director and how was he giving you
context because you had the script
certainly but was he giving you context
in the ways that this was fitting in you
know we obviously we had the this
well-written script and we had these two
incredible memoirs to draw from but and
from that though Felix was very open and
a lot a lot of rehearsals in the
beginning were just for me and Timothy
to to be comfortable with each other and
and find the rhythms of those scenes and
we stretched them every which way and
and if I say well what did what did
happen he's like it's okay we can we can
interpret what it is here for us and so
it didn't feel like that you had to be
so constrained into someone else's exact
memory
because we're never going to be exactly
like the real human being kind of the
tricky part right you want to do it
justice but at the same time it's an
interpretation yeah yes there are
moments that I look at him and I wonder
who he is
how's that boy David never I wanted to
talk about your reasoning behind kind of
going back and forth in time and the way
that the movie was edited because it it
makes perfect sense in how it seems like
a memory it is inspired by two books two
memoirs and they kind of do the same
thing they they tell a story over many
many years I mean if we wanted this
movie to be apik it had to do that too
somehow in the movie it's a long process
it's not a and it's a very organic
process and it obviously it was in the
script already that way but we do when I
go into the Edit room rethink a bunch of
stuff an emotional roller coaster where
it's less cerebral in in writing it's a
reasoning to cut back and forth which
was included in the script is cerebral
razzle as once you're watching a movie
it just has to work in motion what you
have you're gonna find it again you're
gonna get it back do you know how much I
love you
I love you more than everything another
18
everything
everything
you
you